sigamos trabajando con las funciones de
densidad de probabilidad aquí dibuje una
de ellas para una variable aleatoria
como le llamaremos entonces hay que
cambiar un poco no entonces tenemos el
eje y bueno no puedo dibujar la gráfica
para todos los números reales pero
supongamos que para todos los números
aquí a la derecha todos los números
mayores a 5 esta función vale 0 y lo
mismo si evaluamos la función en
cualquier número menor que 1 entonces
también esta función vale 0 y bueno ya
con esto yo te pregunto a ti qué altura
tiene que tener este triángulo para que
ésta esta sea realmente la gráfica de la
función de densidad de probabilidad de
la variable aleatoria g pues bueno para
que realmente sea una función de
densidad de probabilidad lo que necesita
es integrar uno ok y como esta función
vale cero para todos los números mayores
que cinco y vale cero para todos los
números menos que uno bueno eso lo que
nos dice para empezar es que solo toma
valores entre el 1 y el 5 y que además
toda la probabilidad está concentrada en
esta área entonces lo que necesitamos es
que toda esta área sea exactamente igual
a 1 y bueno qué altura tiene que tener
este triángulo para que el área sea
exactamente igual a 1 pues cuando
tenemos un triángulo está como es una
figura muy sencilla pues para calcular
su área lo único que tenemos que hacer
es multiplicar base por altura y
dividirlo entre 2 en este caso la base
mide 5 menos 1 o sea 4 ok entonces
tenemos que uno tiene que ser
exactamente igual a la base que ya vimos
que son cuatro por la altura
justo en nuestra incógnita sobre 2
y a partir de esto podemos encontrar muy
fácil h
de aquí el 2 se consolida con uno de
estos 2
luego dividimos entre dos otra vez ok
vamos a dividir entre 2
entonces lo ponemos aquí 2
key este se cancela con este y nos queda
h igual a un medio
y entonces la altura es igual a un medio
y bueno pudimos calcular esta área muy
fácil porque pues es un triángulo pero
si hubiéramos tenido cualquier otra
curva acá hubieran tenido un pico por
aquí y otro por acá lo que tendríamos
que hacer es calcular todo el área bajo
la curva de esta función y de esta
función que es la función de densidad de
probabilidad que pues también lo podemos
abreviar así y bueno ya que sabemos que
la altura es de un medio ya podríamos
calcular con la expresión algebraica de
estas rectas cuál es exactamente la
función
y bueno esta función de densidad de
probabilidad pues es cero desde menos
infinito hasta el 1 y si estás en el
humor apropiado puedes calcular cuál es
la ecuación de esta recta y la función
de densidad de probabilidad toma esta
ecuación entre el 1 y el 3 y luego es
igual a la ecuación de esta recta entre
el 3 y el 5 y finalmente la función de
densidad de probabilidad tomar los
valores de 0 desde el 5 hasta el
infinito y bueno en la que tenemos
exactamente con la función de densidad
probabilidad pues calculemos algunas
probabilidades que bueno no es nada
nuevo ya hicimos este tipo de cosas
en el vídeo pasado pero ahora es una
función de densidad de probabilidad no
uniforme la lo cual hace que cambie un
poquitito y además seguimos practicando
entonces calculemos con la probabilidad
de que que esté entre 2
y 3
y vamos a necesitar un poco de espacio
entonces la probabilidad de que esté
entre 2 y 3 incluyendo al 2 de al 3
bueno eso significa que la variable
aleatoria g caiga en este intervalo y
para cualquier intervalo el área bajo la
curva de la función de entidad de
probabilidad nos da justo la
probabilidad de que la variable caiga en
ese intervalo ok
pues la probabilidad que se caiga entre
el 2 y el 3 es justo esta área
ahora esta área sigue siendo un área muy
bonita y muy fácil de calcular si
tuviéramos algo extraño por aquí pues
tal vez tendremos que hacer más cálculos
incluso podríamos tener que usar cálculo
integral y ese tipo de herramientas pero
no son necesarias porque por ejemplo
aquí esta área la podemos dividir en
este rectángulo este de aquí y este
triángulo
o también podríamos usar una fórmula
para calcular el área de trapecios eso
si hagamos lo que hagamos nos tienen que
calcular esta altura ahora esta altura
básicamente ya está dada por esta altura
que ya calculamos porque esta es una
línea recta que en dos pasos sube en
medio paso sobre el eje de las veces
entonces en un paso como es una línea
recta
va a tener que subir la mitad de lo que
subió en total o sea va a tener que
subir un cuarto y entonces esta
probabilidad es igual al área del
cuadrado morado que es base 1 por la
altura un cuarto más el área de este
triángulo que tiene la misma base de 1 y
ahora tiene una altura de un cuarto
también no un medio menos un cuarto un
cuarto
y por ser un triángulo por un medio o
sea un cuarto más un octavo lo cual es
igual a estos son dos octavos tres
octavos
esta es la probabilidad de que se caiga
entre el 2 y el 3 son tres octavos que
es este área y ahora te pregunto con la
probabilidad de que que sea exactamente
igual a 3 y esto también lo vimos en el
vídeo pasado y esta probabilidad vale lo
mismo que el área de un rectángulo por
aquí de altura un medio pero con una
base infinitamente pequeña una base de
lo largo de un punto porque aquí la
función de densidad de probabilidad nos
está dando que tendencias la
probabilidad cerca del 3 pero si tenemos
una base tan pequeña una base con una
longitud de un solo punto
entonces el rectángulo en realidad no
tiene masa tiene masa cero o sea
multiplicamos altura que es un medio por
base cero y nos da cero
ok esto es un rectángulo de área 0 y
bueno esto nos lleva a otra pregunta
interesante pues la probabilidad de que
g sea mayor
estricto que 2 y menor estricto que 3 o
sea que tome cualquier valor entre 2 y 3
pero definitivamente no tome el 2003 ok
el escenario en el que g es exactamente
igual a 2 y el escenario en el que es
exactamente igual a 3 no los estamos
considerando dentro de esta probabilidad
ok que puede ser 2.000 0 0001 og puede
ser 2.9 99 9999 todos los nuevos que
quieras a la derecha mientras en una
cantidad finita pero que no puede ser
igual a 3
ok cuál es la probabilidad de que suceda
esto
voy a resulta que va a seguir siendo
igual a tres octavos porque este
trapecio sigue representando a este
evento
ok tal vez le quitamos estas barreras a
estas dos líneas
estos dos rectángulos de base cero y que
también tienen área cero se los quitamos
pero este trapecio sigue teniendo el
mismo área sin estas dos líneas
podríamos decir que este es igual a este
menos 2010 de la probabilidad de que es
exactamente igual a dos y otro cero de
la probabilidad de que es exactamente
igual a tres
y listo